moscou a décidé de jeter l'épongé et
c'est sans doute le dépôt d'une plainte
contre la russie de la part des pays bas
devant la cour européenne des droits de
l'homme qui aura été la goutte de trop
moscou regrette en effet que dans cette
enquête sur le crash du hem h 17
les dés étaient pipés et ce dès le tout
début
depuis le premier jour les pays-bas roi
adhérer à une version de ce qui s'est
passé et l'ont promu à la fois dans le
cadre de l' enquête technique du conseil
de sécurité néerlandais et de l' enquête
pénale menée par l'équipe comme une
banque est naturellement les deux
enquêtes se sont avérées biaisé
superficiel et politisé tout a été fait
pour donner crédit aux accusations
hâtives visant la russie
d'autant que la russie à maintes
reprises a tenté de participer aux
différentes enquêtes en fournissant
diverses pièces à conviction les
propositions qui n'ont jamais été
acceptées
nous considérons qu'en ignorant tous les
arguments de notre volonté de dialogue
les pays-bas poursuivre uniquement des
intérêts politiques conjoncturelles se
cachant sans vergogne derrière la
nécessité de protéger les droits des
proches des victimes de l'accident
pour conclure la russie se dit prête à
continuer à collaborer pour tenter de
faire toute la lumière dans cette
tragédie
conformément à la résolution 21 66 du
conseil de sécurité des nations unies
mais ce ne sera donc plus dans le cadre
de l' enquête menée par les autorités
néerlandaises